I have one that I like call The One That
Got Away why are they the one that got
away he won't let me love him
[Music]
call an ex-lover and ask what went wrong
absolutely not I'm mad at you yeah yeah
it's not because we're in this little
thing and I said yes and I'd be like to
be filmed that you're gonna make me do
everything that I want to do absolutely
not I am not doing that you know why
because that was a problem
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna lie I got a few of those
calls but that's facts I have one that I
like call The One That Got Away why are
they the one that got away
he won't let me love him
whoa oh
[Music]
that's that's I got full life yeah hold
up
I'm sorry I had flashbacks to women like
this that that's that that's a if you've
never had a woman listen or a person
ladies maybe you can relate if you've
never had somebody try to force their
love onto you it is one of the most
revolting things possible when someone's
so dead and you don't want it but they
keep pushing when they try to like give
you affection and like them just
touching you makes your skin crawl like
you're not just in Silver Lake okay
love you baby
but but that is
that's crazy doesn't want to let that me
love him oh that's
sorry that's crazy sorry sorry uh listen
I'm if you're out there and you said
that that that is crazy
if if someone doesn't want
to interact with you you always clinging
to that person it's crazy oh okay hold
on let's let's play this one let's hear
why it's the one you're most nervous to
call
I have one that I like call The One That
Got Away why are they the one that got
away
he won't let me love him what is it
Mental Health
Mental Health it's very self-saint
centered the reason why I say that it's
self-centered is I really just think
about yourself about what you want you
don't care about the other [ __ ] whatever
the other person wants but I know what's
best for him I know that what's best is
us and I really want that is crazy bro
this is the first time someone's made me
cringe so deep in my core yeah my soul
yep he won't let me love him I it's the
not reciprocated feelings that it's just
like that's the one I want
mental health you said it the not
reciprocated feelings is the one I want
ladies how many times is a dude been on
your case
and you've never responded and this
[ __ ] got a whole chat just by
himself that's crazy that's crazy we
dated when I was
maybe 19. I haven't talked to him in a
long time so we'll see if he answers oh
my God if he answers this would be so
weird because that was a secret his
parents are just very very strict people
he would like leave work to hang out
with me so
let's see
hello hey Zig hey okay I'm gonna just
tell you guys ladies or something okay
if
if y'all used to date and y'all stop
dating and it's been a long time and you
call out of nowhere guys are thinking
what the [ __ ]
an X and ask what you think went wrong
with our relationship
sorry put you on the spot
um you no I'd say and then a bunch of
bullshit's about to come up and I'll
tell you why it's gonna be a bunch of
[ __ ] because usually you know you
know it's not even that what what is it
once you're done with somebody you just
don't want no problems yeah
telling somebody the truth normally
involves a lot of problems yes and I'm
not even trying to build a relationship
with you no more and people think they
can't handle so why am I gonna sit here
and argue or try to play therapy or try
to do this whole thing of like this is
how you're [ __ ] up when I don't want
you in my life no more you know what it
works I've had people uh I had people
come up to me years after right and like
the way they were like us breaking up
was so like drawn out like they just
didn't want it and then they asked me
and I'm like
do I want to emotionally invest myself
no into somebody I don't even want to
see again nope
absolutely and that's why you'll just be
like listen sometimes I'll just say it's
me
I'll just say I'm the problem even
though
just listen I've definitely [ __ ] up in
some of my relationships and I take full
accountability I've apologized to these
individuals I've hit them up without
them asking I'm cool with that it
doesn't matter because I had to
apologize for some [ __ ] right in my own
reflection and there's other times where
I'm like no this [ __ ] was crazy or she
was acting a little wild and she don't
want it but it's fine and I'm just like
I'm the problem wonder why
because I'm not gonna lie it's not you
it's me Works people's ass is corny that
[ __ ] works when I want to move on
something it's me I'm stupid I need
therapy I'm [ __ ] let me go home
just leave me the [ __ ] alone please for
the love of God I don't want to be drawn
out of this go ahead and I think that
happened is that sometimes they don't
want the truth
and when they ask for the truth you give
them the truth they think you're lying
and now you have to explain yourself
that you're not lying to someone that
you don't even want to talk to it's a
lot of energy spent for nothing the fact
that I was moving away for school yeah I
think with like my business situation
because if I had an opportunity to save
it I think we would be something else do
you know that I consider you for me the
one that got away
really yeah I know
I appreciate it
what the [ __ ]
hold up that is the that is that is the
way
that should keep someone at Bay that is
crazy well I appreciate it if I say
anything else yes this [ __ ] absolutely
and you want to know something
come back here
see it it's gonna hit you okay
you ever had a lemon in your mouth and
just sucked on the juices yeah
foreign
[Music]
and hang up on you do you
ever think about me yeah I mean you come
on sometimes I love thinking about those
memories I love seeing the pictures like
the wedding we had gone to yeah stuff in
the road trips Portland and I don't
regret anything do you still find me
attractive
attractive
of course are you still seeing that girl
the girl
we just broke up yesterday
I'm so sorry so you know
my girl
if you don't take all your [ __ ] and get
the [ __ ] out of here normally believe
you I'm so sorry
though ain't nobody believe you it's a
bouncer go dance
sorry though ain't nobody believe you
call an ex-lover and ask what went wrong
here we go
this is not gonna go well might just go
straight to voicemail
hello Kiana I have to ask you a question
all right I can already tell myself she
said what listen listen let me tell you
guys I could already tell by the way she
said what that he put her through some
[ __ ]
absolutely she is sick of him already
Yes Why didn't it work out between us
because you're full of [ __ ]
[Applause]
we knew that no no that was it
what what what
of course the way she said what
foreign
he looked like a [ __ ] on the first 48
who got caught with the murder weapon
and got offered some McDonald's he gonna
confess and like yo confess nah man I'm
not about to tell you that it was little
Ray Ray
well here's a Big Mac it was a little
red little Pookie Little Jim Jim
you care to go into that a little bit
more you bit off more than you could
shoot how about that one I did
you find a good one and then when the
follow through came up you were like you
know how the DJ scratches the record
yeah I mean that's what I saw when I
looked at my bank account it says
that's it I've been off more than I
could too good God this girl wants how
much money from me
what is that This girl wants how much
money for me I don't know what that
means I don't know what that means
but that sounded a little weird why did
things not work out between us
wow
this is fine that's lit oh that is hey
hey I don't know who that lady is but
that response immaculately got dumpster
fire is really lit how deep down I liked
it
[ __ ] you still got my number oh yeah
that's good Hey
sir I've definitely been on the
receiving end of that call so I know how
that feels like yo why you calling me uh
the mistake
I just I didn't delete it yeah go ahead
and do that
hey
[Music]
hey that was unbelievable whoa perfect
whoa let's hit that [ __ ] again oh look
at his face
you know he brought me up Antonio
Banderas that meme
[Music]
that's when you're expelling from the
prefrontal cortex so yeah damn that was
oh shout out to this guy for taking that
[ __ ] on the chin yeah yeah cause if I
knew and X hated me that much I wouldn't
call in front of other people unless I'm
making money and I could but I'm never
gonna do that because I was I don't I
just I don't want to get embarrassed
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] what do you want to
know my situation for you I get back
with me I came into some money and I
think I might be able to afford to hang
out with you
punch this [ __ ] out of you and then
leave
see I saw the invited today
she has chosen violence no I'm not even
gonna go that route but she don't want
peace I'm not a lot this one really
should Dynamic I'm not used to I never
had no sugar baby I pay for everything
kind of dynamic so hearing them talk so
kindly about money that being the thing
that they're bridging is very weird to
me inform bye
I have a good life
ah it hurt for her to react like that
she must have done a lot she's done done
yeah yeah she done she made man let's
just stop here we'll do the second half
another time we could definitely do the
second half what the if you guys want to
see a part two to this and you guys
enjoyed today's video Let's see it let
us know in the comments below leave
comments engage with it leave a like if
this gets to 50K likes we'll do a part
two because this [ __ ] was wild 700 date
oh by the way dude who had to pay for
the 700 date if you see this contact us
or if you guys know who he is tell him
to contact us we want to ask some
questions we might have 700 for him to
go to a date but we don't film that [ __ ]
because you know we're gonna get a punch